what they have done is learned this is
what Harry does now he doesn't just
attack them once he just goes on and on
and on you know with Netflix with Opera
winley the first and then that and then
moaning to everybody who he comes to and
I feel very strongly that he would have
known what would be in this book and
he's done absolutely nothing about it I
thought he would say you know he's very
ke on suing people they said this is an
invasion of my privacy and I won't have
it or say I had nothing to do with this
I'm so sorry everyone but he hasn't done
that and I think that the royal family
have to get thicker skin and actually
just get on with things